Hãy của thang vận rất đại diện 2 bộ ngoại sáng Trung Quốc và Nhật Bản tại Bắc Tinh, ngày 18,
mấy một, phía Trung Quốc đã yêu cầu Chu Kio thu hồi phán ngôn của tụ tướng Sân này ta kỳ chi,
lên quan đến phán tệ Đài Luan, như phán ngôn mang nền cho biết, Trung Quốc phản đối mạnh mẽ
kinh nhận định mà Bắc Tinh lấy sá là Sái Lịch, vì phạm lực pháp của tế và đi ngược lại tinh thần
của các phân kỳ chính trị giải nước. Chuong có trò rằng những pháp bởi ngay anh hưởng em chào đến nền tảng
trị của quân hệ sống phương và làm xác các bất định trong dưới lạch trong lức. Theo chuyền thông nhận bản,
phải đoàn cho Kio nhiều khả năng không đồng ý với yêu cầu dú lại phán ngôn,
khiến chiển vào pháp băng quan hệ vẫn chưa chất chắn, chứ tìm hình căn thẳng,
Nhật bản đã cạnh báo công dân tại Trung Quốc tăng cận các biển pháp an toàn,
chứ khi đó chú có tuyên bố, thu tướng lý cường không có kế hoàn gặp lãnh đại dạng
bản tại gồm hai người và đã chủ tập đại xưa Chu Kio để phản đối.
Như dưới biển cân đầy phản em đồng nhận cảm của các bạn đi đài loàn,
cho quan hệ hệ hành hước và chứ thấy khả năng đối thoại tiếp theo vẫn còn nhiều tích tức.